i'm very happy to have sean
uh here today to tell us about results
in
uh the complexity of uh reinforcement
learning
all right thanks peter and uh definitely
a huge thanks to the the simons
institute for convening uh everyone
together so
this talk is going to switch gears from
looking at natural intelligence to
the artificial bases of intelligence in
particular we're going to look at this
reinforcement learning problem where we
have an agent which wants to
maximize some long-term performance
measure in a possibly uncertain world so
you know like john's answer to boraz's
question earlier
in these ad based systems we might be
interested in
finding some way to
improve a long-term quality measure of
the system as opposed to myopic
myopically just showing ads and one of
the challenges with challenges we face
in these
complex systems is just that you know
there are the high dimensional problems
we have uncertainty and underlying this
is we have this problem of
generalization
okay so let's just uh mention a few
things with regards to generalization in
the supervised learning setting so in
this setting you know when i think of
one of these data sets where we
someone has annotated
uh what's the the object in various
images
okay and in these settings we have a
pretty good idea of how generalization
is possible
okay and it's basically due to the fact
that on a data set we can
try out various classifiers and see how
well they do
and
we have a pretty good uh theoretical
basis of how this happens as well like
you know we're basically doing well
before we see every possible image in
the world okay and
uh you know there's various settings we
have some theory here which is for
linear models we know what's going on uh
there's a growing set of complexity
measures which which characterize the
sample size we need and even in deep
learning settings we have a pretty good
idea of the capacity in fact like peter
was one of the pioneers in some of the
early work on capacity measures of new
in euro settings
okay and
we can think about the problem of
generalization as really just being
analogous to the supervised one in the
sense that we'd like to do well before
seeing every possible state in the world
you know we'd like to do well before uh
hitting every game configuration in this
game
okay so we'd like to do well
with a number of samples that's far
fewer than the number of possible states
in the world and that's really this the
question of
that we're going to look at in this talk
how can we understand this issue of
generalization in these rich interactive
settings
in particular we're gonna also think of
this uh
perspective from tcs it's very helpful
to look at lower bonds to see what is
impossible which will give give us
insights into what types of assumptions
we need uh for when it is possible okay
so the first part is really going to be
giving us some new insights uh with
regards to looking at lower bounds uh
and once we understand that we'll switch
to
uh upper bounds
okay the the notation we'll use is uh
somewhat standard in rl we'll try to
keep it notation light but this uh mdp
setting is one agent we take an action a
uh that advances the state the next
state is sampled from some underlying
stochastic process okay and a policy is
some behavioral mapping which maps tapes
states to actions okay and in terms of
two quantities we'll refer to as this
value function and the q function so the
value function at a state s when we
execute policy pi is just our future
reward say for
capital h steps starting at state s and
this q function this one step look at
value as we start at state s
then we take action a so we deviate from
what we're doing then we follow pi okay
so that's this q function you can think
of as like a one step look ahead i'm at
s i take action a then i follow pi and
it's my expected future reward uh
from that configuration
okay and we'll specify the goals later
but we're interested in long-term
performance measures
okay so so let's start with lower bounds
and basically consider one of the the
bread and butter cases where
let's try to see what will happen when
we look at linear models okay
and in fact let's actually look at a
somewhat simpler question
which would be that of offline
reinforcement learning so in a lot of
practical settings uh
you know we've collected data in some
matter in which we're interacting with
the world but we've just logged it all
and we have a bunch of data sitting
around that we've logged okay and now
what can we do with that okay so so
we're going to look at this setting
where we're no longer interacting with
the world that we
just have a bunch of log data but we're
interested in say evaluating how some
policy will work so the simplest
question here
would just be this offline evaluation
problem so we we've got a bunch of data
sampled
according to the underlying dynamics our
data so it looks like a state the action
we took to the next state and the reward
okay and we just want to evaluate what
would have happened if we execute some
policy pi so we just want to get a
measure of how good a fixed policy is
okay and what's nice about this setting
is we can start looking at this in a way
where we have gotten rid of the
interactive component we just want to do
evaluation
okay
so what are the some of the challenges
here with regards to evaluating a fixed
policy
we can't run causal
experiments here because it's we have
observational data and you know we might
not have enough
data in various groups
uh and on top of that we have this
course of dimensionality there's just a
lot of possible
uh you know patient configurations and
treatments we can do yes i'm just using
a running example from healthcare we
just have a lot of log data for
sequential treatments and we want to
evaluate some new treatment but we want
to evaluate this new treatment using the
data we've collected
okay so so let's try to get some
intuition for when this is possible by
looking at a simpler a slightly simpler
setting which is a horizon one problem
so let's forget about the sequential
decision-making nature of this problem
and think of this as a one-shot setting
so here our data sets is going to be a
state which is going to be
some
patient characteristics or action is
going to be a treatment and a reward is
going to be some measure of the
performance outcome okay and now let's
think of this as a one-shot game so
there's no next state
okay and our goal is just to evaluate
say
how some treatment will work on a new
patient
the problem is this is just a lot of
patient characteristics so
let's look at one of the the simplest
way to address this problem is with a
linear model suppose we have some
feature mapping phi whose dimension is
much
smaller than the number of possible
uh people and treatments out there okay
and and the hope is that
because we're using utilizing this maybe
good future mapping this can allow us to
generalize to new patients again and
let's suppose for a moment we posit that
the performance metric is linear in this
feature mapping
okay so so when will this work like what
are the properties we need uh for our
offline data set to allow us to forecast
what would happen with a new patient and
this is like the simplest possible
setting we've got this offline data set
we have a linear model
uh what can we say about a new person
okay so when does this work
okay so we're going to make this
realizability assumptions often what we
call it machine learning let's just
suppose the linear model is correct that
there is that this linear relationship
is actually true that that the outcome
per person is going to be linear in the
futures plus some additive noise
okay that alone if you think about it
isn't enough to do well because
we might not have coverage in our data
set right like suppose all the features
are the same feature we
this this isn't enough information to
tell us what would happen on a new
patient
okay so we'll make this a coverage
assumption which is if we look at our
offline data set and we look at the
covariance matrix
it's kind of fat in all directions
okay so this basically means we're not
missing directions in our feature space
okay so um you know if we think about
linear systems this is kind of saying uh
we have a well-conditioned linear system
okay so under these two assumptions
uh
with a moderate amount of offline data
we'll be able to estimate the linear
relationship with least squares okay we
just fit the line
and
with a moderate amount of data we'll
have the property that for any new
inputs or any new patient treatment we
have a good forecast of what'll happen
okay and it's important here that this
is true for any
for any any person that comes in
okay under these two assumptions so
uniformly we're good under these
assumptions okay but again so so this is
the horizon one problem right because
we're not assuming that there's a
sequential decision making problem in
this h equals one setting
okay so now let's turn back to our uh
evaluation problem for
trying to figure out what happens over
eight stages
okay and let's try to
think about how we might
how we might do
this okay and let's let's think of
let's write down two very natural
assumptions uh and try to think about
the implications of this and we're going
to extend it from the horizon one
setting
so we want to uh estimate how good some
sequential treatment is and let's
suppose right now that we have some
features and that the long-term value
function of our treatment is linear in
these features so at every stage uh the
long-term value is linear in in these
features so the idea is this would
hopefully help us solve the curse of
dimensionality
okay and just like the horizon one
problem uh we know this isn't enough
right we need we need some more
assumptions but let's also suppose we
have coverage in the sense that our
covariance matrix of these features is
uh well conditioned
okay so we've got both these things we
assume our linear relationship is true
everywhere and we assume
uh we've got
sort of a
spectral coverage that the covariance
matrix everywhere is good
okay and why is this in
um
you know why is this a natural starting
point well we can think about an
algorithm which works which works by
moving backwards right the last stage
this is our h equals one problem we just
run regression we uniformly know what's
happening
okay and if we know what's happening at
the last stage for every person it's not
just on average for every person we have
a pretty good idea of what's happening
under these assumptions
and then the idea is we try to move
backwards we're going to take our
estimate at the last stage plug it into
uh some estimation procedure going
backwards and keep trying to move
backwards okay and we've got coverage so
in a spectral sense we're not really
missing any data
okay so the question is will this work
okay this sort of backward uh
induction approach
okay and we can ask like statistically
will this work for any algorithm not
just this backward induction approach
okay so formally
uh
what we're saying is that
we have some features
that a long-term value function for all
sort of state action pairs at all stages
is linear in these features this is a
very strong assumption we're assuming
our linear model is correct
and we're assuming that our feature or
covariance matrix is well conditioned
okay so we're not missing directions in
our data
and now we have this question can we
actually evaluate how a policy
will behave how do we uh if we run it
okay so the first result is
actually a bit disappointing it shows
that these two assumptions are not
enough to do offline policy evaluation
in particular it says
for any algorithm and the algorithm can
know the features you cannot evaluate
a given policy
okay you need the number of samples you
need is going to be exponential in
the horizon so at h equals 1 this worked
fine
but you have this error amplification
effect so if you did this backup
algorithm you'd have this error
amplification effect but it turns out
this is true for
uh for any algorithm
that information theoretically you
cannot beat this
um any and
you can give a finer grain
characterizations of this
and some intuition here is what's going
on is if we did this backward induction
approach
uh
it gives us an unbiased estimate but the
variance is blowing up
and this is a little disheartening in
the sense that you know if we put a
practical hats on we don't believe the
models
we have like oftentimes linear
relationships don't hold data on iid
we're missing groups but this is a
setting that even in the best case
scenario where the linear model is
correct and we have coverage we should
not
necessarily expect it to work
okay so so somehow fundamentally when we
start looking at the interactive
learning problem it really is different
than the supervised learning problem the
way errors amplify
okay and
this is real in practice too we can come
up with settings where we kind of mix
data from two sources we can come up
with the reasonable ways to train deep
learned features
and we create a mixed data set we try to
evaluate see this running policy and we
see our amplification so i'm just using
this for to highlight that this actually
occurs in practice
okay so now let's turn to the online
problem okay so so that was the offline
setting let's look at the online
reinforcement learning problem
okay so what are the challenges in the
online setting the online setting is
where we act for a while collect
feedback and then you know we repeat in
some episodic manner
okay so now we've got to actually handle
the exploration problem because we act
randomly we might not discover things
we've got the credit assignment problem
we make an error we've got to figure out
which action the past
we should attribute to causing this
error
and we've got you know these problems of
large state state spaces and action
spaces this is this uh
open ai demo from a couple years ago the
the algebraic part doesn't really matter
the point here is
we're trying to do rl in you know
complex systems
okay and
so again we're going to be thinking so
now we're going to think about this
online setting where we start at some
state we act for a while and we repeat
and our goal now is rather than
evaluation we want to find you know we
want to find a policy which
approximately maximizes a long term
uh performance measure in this unknown
mdp
again again we're
trying to do this with a small number of
samples and we're interested in this
question of generalization so again
let's start with
uh this simple setting of what can we
get at with a linear model and in
particular let's suppose the optimal
value function is linear in some
features like is this enough to do
sample efficient reinforcement learning
okay and and this has been an
uh an open question for quite some time
okay and it turns out that
under this linear realizability
assumption
we still can't do rl in the online
setting so formally it says we take this
optimal
q function suppose it's linear in these
features
and we'll actually make life easier
that
we're going to assume that
the answer
is
kind of has a margin in the sense that
the best action is substantially better
than the second best action in every
state so the hope now is it should be
easy to actually i identify the best
policy itself
okay
now it turns out that under this
assumption
um
we still can't do
efficient reinforcement learning in that
for any algorithm
you know assuming that
um
we have this linear linear realizable
mdp and we have this gap
and the algorithm can know the features
if the algorithm does well it will still
need an exponential number of samples in
either the dimension or the horizon to
do well
okay and uh
this was definitely a a question people
have been looking at in the community
for a while
uh the you know it's a series of papers
but this paper by weiss i would say this
is really one of the breakthrough papers
in uh starting to understand this and
you know this is a lot like a question
of you know having an lp
with some known features and trying to
solve this lp with a certain type of
query access
except this
uh
except we know the corresponding lp
corresponds to an mdp
okay but this negative result is
basically telling us that you know taken
collectively this is really saying
to do rl we need to be thinking
differently than
the way we think about supervised
learning because the analogs of these
assumptions in supervised learning when
the horizon is one we can do them these
are the standard linear modeling
assumptions we make in supervised
learning but when you start moving to
the rl setting both for offline and
online it really breaks down
okay and that's bringing us to the
question of
what are sufficient conditions
right because
the the ways we think about supervised
learning if we just say hey
we can model things with linear features
in terms of the policy or the optimal
value function in terms of the uh a
policy's value or the q star value
function
we're not able to do things efficiently
so this is this is telling us we're
going to need stronger assumptions
and what's the nature of those
assumptions
okay in particular you know the one one
of the ways we think about supervised
learning we have some type of hypothesis
class an rl it could be some set of
policies values or mdps and we're trying
to understand what are the types of
assumptions we need to make so we can do
rl efficiently where the number of
samples we need to do it
is not a function of the number of
states in the world and it's a function
of say some complexity measure of the
class
okay so we definitely need stronger
assumptions because
the simplest linear modeling assumptions
won't work but what's the nature of
these assumptions and once we start
thinking about that then it's i think it
starts giving us insight into what's
going on so i'm just going to highlight
um one such
assumption to to contrast this to kind
of show you why
the way we get upper bounds really does
need to um we do need to make more
complicated assumptions
okay so i'll give one historical example
of where rl does work
this is this
bellman completeness assumption so
suppose f is a class of linear functions
so these are functions linear in some
features
okay so the bellman backup operator is a
little technical but if you have some
function the bellman backup operators
you add the reward it's like this greedy
one step look ahead backup operator when
you're doing dynamic programming so t of
f is just r plus you know the expected
uh greedy thing at the next state
okay so
this uh completeness assumption you
should really think about just closure
that when if you have a linear function
in the class and you back it up it's
going to remain a linear function
so that's the assumption now so this is
stronger than the assumption of saying
q star is linear this is saying when we
back things up
it remains linear
and
making this assumption it's much
stronger than the assumptions we had
before okay so one reason it's stronger
is if you add a feature to this
assumption
you could break it
right like when we have a if we're
saying some function is linear and phi
if you add a future to it it doesn't
break that property but here if you
think about this completeness assumption
if you add features it could break the
assumption
and this is disappointing because it
sort of goes against
a lot of the things we believe in
machine learning and in a practical part
of machine learning because there we
want to make models big because we're
hoping to better approximate the world
but here as you add richness to your
model you might be breaking this
property because you somehow need to
make sure these features behave in some
reasonable way under the dynamics
but under this assumption you can do rl
efficiently
and we might be interested in you know
what are the other conditions in which
sample efficient rl is possible we're
already seeing
that to do rl from a sampler sample
efficient point of view
we do need to change the way we're
thinking about the problem a bit
and
just to end with a sort of a picture on
uh what's been going on in some of the
community that we kind of have these
extremes here we can do rl efficiently
for these small problems like tabular
mdps where it's a big table
and then these other extremes like this
linear q star you can't do it
efficiently and we're trying to figure
out
what's the the space in between of
what types of models we can do rl
efficiently for and when we can
okay and like over the years people have
been proposing various special cases for
when you can do rl efficiently
and there's been a growing set of
complexity measures which govern when
you can do things efficiently
so one of the most important ones here
was this bellman rank condition
is really ahead of its time it has
really captured some of the structural
properties of when we can do rl
efficiently
there's a more recent one which i think
generalized this notion
but what's helpful with these complexity
measures is we can look at our class and
we can see that hey under these
conditions it's easy for us to tell that
we can do it efficiently and it makes it
easier to design new settings or rl is
efficient
but of course there's things that might
lie outside this region and we know
there's one that you know this this
other setting you can do things
efficiently and for a min max point of
view we might be asking the question of
you know can we really come up with an
abstract lower bond which tells us that
for some hypothesis class
can we learn it efficiently
it's not obviously this this is possible
but in some recent work
you can actually characterize things in
an abstract sense that basically given
any hypothesis class so for example
consider the set of models consistent
with the linear q star assumption
there's this
coefficient this decision estimation
coefficient which really does give you a
lower bound telling you
when
you can do sample efficient rl uh
efficiently
so let me just uh wrap things up so
and what's been happening in the last
couple years is trying to understand the
properties in rl that allow us to learn
and the main point i want to get across
in the lower bounds is that
you know when we start doing rl
efficiently we really need to be
exploiting some types of structure in
our problem it's not the supervised
learning setting where
you just have some hypothesis class you
get id data and things tend to work we
really need to have uh some type of
underlying structure in the problem and
to exploit this in order to get sample
efficient algorithms
um and and you know i've really been
highlighting work from the community
over the last couple years i just wanted
to call out a couple of uh the students
involved who are heavily involved in
this work with the rue song
uh wang
mohagen who's here and yunho wang
and finally um
you know really a big thanks to the
simon's institute and uh going back to
shafi's point of how
you know a lot of these programs are
uh really expanding the lens of what
we're doing here so you know some of
these workshops i i'm referring to here
this
theory of rl program for a semester in
foundations ml really we're bringing
together the the theoretical computer
science community with the ml community
and a lot of the ideas that i presented
here were really things that had been
discussed at these workshops and some of
them people have been made making
progress while there and and definitely
a huge thanks to peter and alastair for
for their help over the last couple
years so thanks a lot
thanks sean
questions yes
[Music]
thank you for the talk a quick question
do you have any insights on based on
this work on for example when you look
at like go the success of go
all of these assumptions break assuming
right uh they're seven non-linear model
and
there is no
uh
yeah so if you can
you just want to understand wrap my
header
where does that model fit assuming you
know that model is a good journalism
model
yeah that's right so in a sense like the
the reason
we're thinking about this from the
theory point of view is we want better
algorithms here and those of us who also
play around with the practical side of
rls rl doesn't really just work out of
the box like in supervised learning yes
we need to think about architectures but
at the end of the day you get a lot of
data a reasonable architecture run sgd
often things work this does not happen
in rl and and part of this picture here
is to
is to try to understand like other
natural algorithms that can
exploit uncertainty and
where we can can kind of replace the
linear parts with nonlinear parts so
these like bilinear classes and stuff
like that that's moving on to like
non-linear hypothesis classes
and in in the case of go i think one
thing is this
aspect that you don't seem to need deep
exploration here that just sort of
playing randomly you discover new
patterns and you can kind of do gradient
descent that'll work
so
you know so that's one type of problem
uh where if we think about i think
gradient-based method there is a theory
which can help us there but there is a
sense in which like a look at you know
moderate amounts of look-ahead search
along with local search seems to do
pretty well
and
in other settings that type of
exploration does not work and that's
where unlike supervisor learning the
word really does shatter in rl like the
specifics of the problem really are
coupled with generalization
all right one more question i mean yeah
so i have a technical question uh about
you know you wanted to have this uniform
for every a and s
but maybe that is not a
feasible goal maybe
you don't want to have for every single
ans a good prediction or you know
maybe we should not think about that you
know uh you know maybe these states and
actions are just
so remote
that you should not even think about
yeah okay so i i mean this question this
is a great question so the question is
like look if we think about the some of
the assumptions we're making we're kind
of saying uniformly
we're able to predict what would happen
at least in a value-based sense
everywhere in the world
okay so this is sort of the
two two answers here that
um
from the lower point of view this is
only stronger that
uh but you know
relaxing it
will only make make it easy you know
it only makes the problem harder so so
making the problem easier and you still
can't do it and and the problem with rl
is
and this is why it's different in
supervised lending and supervised
learning all we care about is our
average error for the most part okay and
in practice yeah we want to do better
but in rl the the reason is that
uh
we do need to extrapolate because
suppose like the optimal thing never
goes there but maybe
if we don't evaluate what's happening
there well we'll go there because we
think it's good and there is a sense in
which uh extrapolation forces us to
uniformly do well and and that's kind of
what we're trying to get at here like to
what extent
can we break somehow uniformly doing
well but this is really
based on this meta point and why these
lower bonds are so helpful to us because
they're really saying that to get rl to
work it's very different from supervised
learning and you actually you know kind
of all the assumptions we need we
actually kind of have to do well at
extrapolation and understand what might
happen in other crazy parts of the space
because you know should we go explore
this area some some something needs to
tell us that we shouldn't go explore
this area and that really is
um
more uniform approximation of how well
we're doing everywhere
all right wheels
might stop there for the break thanks
let's thank sean again